that's her and then I kept finding out
about these female inventors and then I
would research them or these female
business owners and I would research
them I'd be like okay thank you these
smarty pants female business owners oh
my God
all of them their husbands did most of
the work that's the crazy thing I
couldn't believe it I was like okay this
next I would find one chick and I would
be like okay this chick has to be the
smarty pants we're looking for this
woman they say that women are smarter
than men
so I'm just looking and this is I think
they make up these studies I really do I
think they make up these studies I think
they make up these IQ tests to make
women feel like we do more than we
actually do